[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have the new ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon ladies gentlemen say
thank you to all of you
they've come out this afternoon this
show your gratitude and respect to this
family but what we need you all to do to
help us today we must socially lead this
is ourselves
you must Sophie this is ourselves we
need anyone who have a mask please put
your mass is on me myself this is
ourselves and if you're sitting in the
seat it did not have your name on it
you're actually sitting in the wrong
seat this plenty seats there's many
seats up in the balcony
there's many seats next door but we do
want to please cooperate with us and
let's show this family the dignity that
they deserve is that all right can I get
somebody see this is a truth try get
somebody say Amen let's show this family
the dignity that they deserve and if you
come here to show them your respect it
really shouldn't matter where you see it
so thank you so much for your
cooperation and god bless you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] I will
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen we
need everyone to please take a seat the
family is here
we need the center I also said that all
clear we need anyone in the center aisle
to my left in your right please clear
that out so the family can proceed in
and take their seats
you also need everyone to please cut
yourself on off please cut off your
cellphone's unless receive this family
with dignity thank you so much for
coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
skitty ladies and gentlemen again we
need you to socially this is yourself
it's every other seat please man please
service sitting there looking after
someone they please socially decision to
do so much for your cooperation thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon you may be seated my name
is Robin Wilkerson and I am the co
Chancellor of North Central University
to all the friends and the family of
George Floyd and all of our esteemed
guests here today I want to welcome you
on behalf of the University on behalf of
dr. Scott Hagan president on behalf of
the Board of Regents on behalf of the
faculty we're so grateful that you're
here with us today and we're honored
that you have come to mourn the loss and
celebrate the life of mr. George Floyd
on behalf of everyone here I want to
personally express our deepest
condolences for this tragic loss now to
open this service the celebration of his
life we will have a scripture reading
from Reverend Jerry McAfee pastor of New
Salem Missionary Baptist Church followed
by an opening prayer from dr. Scott
Hagin president of North Central
University and a solo by mrs. Tawana
Porter
on behalf of the pastors and preachers
from Minneapolis and st. Paul the bloods
on the southside Gangster Disciples and
Vice Lords on the south on the Northside
Psalms 27 the Lord is my light in my
salvation whom shall I fear
the Lord is the strength of my life whom
shall I be afraid when the wicked even
mine enemies and my foes came upon me to
eat up my flesh they stumbled and fell
though and host should encamp against me
my heart shall not fear the war should
rise against me in this will I be
confident one thing if I desired of the
Lord that will I seek after and I may
dwell in the house of the Lord all the
days of my life to behold the beauty of
the Lord and to enquire in his temple
for in the time of trouble he shall hide
me in his pavilion and the secret of his
Tabernacle she hired me he shall set me
up upon a rock just once again on behalf
of North Central University I want to
welcome the Floyd family to our campus
this is truly an undeserved honor for
our University I've been praying all
week that this sacred space would become
a table of healing for the Floyd family
for the city of Minneapolis and for the
world that is grieving beyond these
walls in just a moment I want to offer a
brief prayer but before I offer that
brief prayer I just want to announce as
president of this school the institution
of the George Floyd Memorial Scholarship
even even before announcing this
scholarship yesterday unsolicited over
$53,000 was handed to me to contribute
toward the educational promise of
aspiring young black American leaders
but what I really want to say far beyond
North Central University I am now
challenging every University president
in the United States of America to
establish your own George Floyd Memorial
Scholarship Fund
[Applause]
[Applause]
so people across this nation can give to
the college of their choice it is time
to invest like never before in a new
generation of young black Americans who
are poised and ready to take leadership
on our nation so university presidents
let's step up together I want to invite
you now to pray with me if you will Lord
your word in proverbs 31 is dynamically
clear it says to speak up for those who
cannot speak for themselves ensure
justice for those being crushed yes
speak up for the poor and the helpless
and see that they get justice Lord we
are asking today for you to take this
table of healing here in Minneapolis
today and multiply this healing all over
this nation as part of that now never
fading voice crying out on behalf of
those who have been and who are now
being crushed in body and spirit at this
table of healing today Lord we ask that
you touch the Floyd family was
supernatural comfort and grace that they
may be granted a few moments of respite
as their beloved father and brother and
son is remembered in a way that honors
his life in his personal faith in Jesus
Christ at this table of healing we are
asking you Lord to show us the way our
city and nation are becoming rightfully
despondent with neighbors set against
neighbor help us to repent not just seek
to restore as a nation as cities as
universities and as religious
communities he'll make new and help us O
Lord rebuild our national family and
finally Lord at this table of healing
today we're asking you to search our
hearts as pastors rabbis priests Imams
business leaders politicians and
educators help us reconcile our failed
witness and lead us forward as caring
neighbors and diligent gatekeepers of
mutuality and mercy
guide this generation to change the
national narrative on race and power and
change all of our hearts until they
match your heart we ask all of these
things in the name above all names Jesus
Christ
[Applause]
[Music]
zing gray how the sound
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
wonderful thank you thank you thank you
we're going to have the opportunity now
to hear in just a moment from loved ones
friends and family George Floyd but
before that I would like to welcome to
the podium attorney Benjamin Crump for
his remarks would you please welcome I'm
attorney Ben Crump and along with
attorney Tony Raman new Qi an attorney
Chris Stewart as my co-counsel out front
seeking justice seeking justice seeking
justice for the family of George Florida
along with a lot of other great
attorneys who are working in the
background who I will mention briefly
before we bring up the ones who knew
George Floyd all of his life
I want to thank lawyers towing in the
vineyards like Devin Jacob Chris O'Neil
Lee Merritt Darryl parks Jasmine ran
bill Pentos and Carol Powell xyn because
Europe may see Tony and Chris and I but
it's a whole team of lawyers who are
working because it's going to take a
United
effort fighting in the courtroom and
outside the courtroom to get justice for
George Floyd I will tell you all that
because of the corona virus pandemic we
have to stay on a strict schedule and we
all help to do this social distancing
but I want to just put it on the record
Reverend Al that it was not the corona
virus pandemic that killed George
Florida I want to make it clear on the
record was that other pandemic that we
are far too familiar with in America
that pandemic of racism and
discrimination that killed George
Florida so before we make a plea to
justice we feel it appropriate that you
hear from the people who really knew
George the boy knew George the
adolescent knew George the man and from
whence George came so I would ask that
his brother Polonius Floyd his brother
Rodney Floyd his cousin Sherita taked
his nephew Brandon Williams please come
to the stage and I would ask attorney
Tony Ramanuja an attorney Chris Stewart
to come and stand with me behind them as
united they tell the world why we should
celebrate the life of George Florida
please come up family
[Applause]
[Music]
well are y'all doing first
my name is felonious Floyd brother
George Floyd well we come up to we
didn't have much our mom did what she
could we would sleep in the same bed
play video games together go outside and
you know play catch with the football
and I used to say to myself like man you
can't throw you can't throw it all you
know I mean because the ball never came
to me and uh years down the line cuz I
was catching with one hand two hands
anyway you threw it I start being able
to catch it he said I can throw him but
I just wanted you to go get the ball the
ball don't need to come to you you need
to go get the ball but you know my
brother we did a lot of things together
from like talking with my mom dancing
with my mom cooking with our mom
brothers and sisters and so much we made
banana mayonnaise sandwiches together
you know
it was it was a family thing you know
every day we know when we come in the
house our Mama's gonna have a huge plate
of food separate from each other and we
will
sit there and I'll go with you said who
played it was and I'm like again like 10
I live in I'm talking about the plate
with six pieces of chicken his mind and
he way bigger than me
you know man he's huge so ma'am from
from that being in the house with my
brother man it was just like inspiring
to other people because my mom used to
take in other kids and most of them was
George's friends and they wanted to stay
with her they loved her you know and my
brother he was okay with it so then you
had three to me they were grown din
because they kicked me out the room they
are three men like sixteen seventeen
they grown sleeping in the same bed
waking up going to the same school and
they wouldn't leave each other at all
they always wanted to be with each other
at all times
I remember nights when the day before
school we didn't have a washing machine
so we would all go in and put our socks
and underwear in a bathroom sink and
just start watching them and watching
them and we didn't have detergent we
would use soap but we were watching it
we were gonna be clean okay so we were
literally then right after that we would
take the socks and hang them over to hot
water heating and we'll take the
underwear and hang them over there and
we will fight about it me and his
friends and all of you like no no no you
did it last night because your clothes
pilot still beat up the next day if you
don't put it on hot water heater so from
from that and we learn a lot of stuff
but it's crazy because we were like we
didn't have a dryer so the fastest way
to dry your clothes was to put it in the
oven and let it let it dry faster like
that so it was just van I love my
brother man we had so many memories you
know together
I remember him waking me up telling me
hey man can you hire my clothes
and I look at him but then I look at his
side and I say you right big bro you
right it was this it was just amazing
everywhere you go and see people how
they cling to him they wanted to be
around him
you know George he was like a general
every day he walks outside he'd be a
line of people like just like we came in
wanting to greet him and wanted to have
fun with him
guys that was doing drugs like smokers
and homeless people you couldn't tell
because when you spoke to George
they felt like they was the president
because that's how he made you feel he
was he was powerful man he had a way
with words he could always make you
ready to jump and go all the time
everybody loves George we didn't call
him George
we called him period if you if you
called him Perry you knew him direct you
know cuz George was the name everybody
called a big George a big Flo it you
know Georgie Porgie has so many
different names but I'm gonna go here
and I'm this man is crazy all these
people came to see my brother and that's
amazing to me that he touched so many
people hearts you know could he been
touching our hearts you know you come to
third war where we're from
people are crying right now that's how
much they love them you know I'm just
staying strong as I can because I need
to get it out I need to get it out
everybody want justice we want justice
for George he's gonna get it he's gonna
get it
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone I'm just gonna
echo some of the things that Fallone has
talked about and that is that we come
from a long line of large family members
our mothers were siblings of 13 and if I
can kind of fast forward a little bit
my aunt moved to she lived in Houston
and she would always talk about being
there not having any of her siblings
close close to her so my mother decided
to move to the Houston area back early
80 81 and so we we came to Houston and
we were all excited that we could have
somebody close to us because the only
time we really would see each other is
like during the holidays or when people
would travel to visit my grandmother
long story short I mean we didn't have a
whole lot but we always had each other
and we always were taught that you know
we could always bring other people into
the fold always no one should ever go
home
without having a meal or having food and
so that's how has he talked about my
aunt was someone in the community
everybody they called him a [ __ ] and
all the kids loved to come over there
and she ended up having you know 30 or
40 kids that would come over there
because they always knew that they could
get something to eat if they came there
and not only food but they could be
loved and they could feel a part of the
fold so we were raised to always welcome
people in and to embrace other people
and so you can see as all these people
no matter who you talk to they will all
say the same thing and that it's George
was somebody who was always welcoming
always made people feel like that they
were special and nobody let felt left
out and he would enter into a room
everybody would feel like they were
special he would embrace them as I think
about the thing that I will miss about
him most is his hugs like he was this
great big giant and when he would when
he would wrap his arms around you you
just feel like you know you were
everything could just go away any
problems you had any
turned your head would go away so while
we're all breathing I just want to kind
of highlight his children you know
Quincy javion tangen iike tyson and
Gianna and his three-year-old
granddaughter journey we all need prayer
but if I am honest about it
we are more concerned about his children
and his grandchildren so I asked as you
pray for us as we go along this marathon
to make sure that justice is served on
George's behalf or Perry as we call him
ask that you pray for us and especially
for their children thank you I am riding
the floor youngest brother of Joyce Lord
and brother PJ was talking about
childhood memories and how we grew up
and I would like to start waiting fo we
didn't have much growing up but all that
great stuff I was dried and washed our
clothes that would just ingenuity
innovation we were we had but didn't
have much but we had a house full of
love and I mean I appreciate the love of
everyone in here in this state of
Minneapolis y'all adopted my brother and
showed him so much love and we feel that
love in your city and thankfully
everybody impressed around the world
it's a beautiful thing this great love
we receiving and enjoys Florida's
receiving because he would love it I
wish was here in a presence in the flesh
to see it picks out this great unity he
would bringing it to you if I could
bringing us but maybe my brother big Flo
it's cooking wise he would make me
honest to him and other brother three
gentleman my brother Mitchell grew up in
our house so they would say liberal you
make the best grilled cheese can you
please go make this what I did this
numerous times I realized as I got older
y'all just using me
happy to be doing Big Brother I mean
great guy great gentleman great man and
at the child without no father figure he
was Big Brother but I didn't see the
little stuff they were throwing on he
was doing the best he can and the
mistakes he made and I watching them
follow him corrected myself as a grown
man as a change growing up and you know
learning from him how to be a man
everything hear stories and told us he
was doing him but he was teaching us how
to be a man cuz he was in this world
already before us he gave us a lot of
great lessons and I mean one thing about
a man keep the definition as easy florid
responsibility he was standing up for
his family and friends and he's great at
that and I want you guys to know that he
was standing up clean any injustice
everyone can yell please say his name
thank you I'm Brandon Williams George's
nephew no I call him Pierre
you know we happen to share the same
middle name for some reason my mama
wanted to name all of us after some
other siblings and coincidentally I
ended up with George growing up I mean
I'm a lot you know getting them but my
grandmother raised me I'd have a father
figure present in my life so I grew up
in the same house with him and you know
my uncle's were more of a father figure
in my life and we're in the Alpha middle
you know I gravitated to him it's coming
up I play sports he did you know they
kind of connected us brought us real
close on and tried not to be sad this is
a lot harder than I thought it would be
um I just just remember
I just remember just all of the memories
man so more than anything I just want to
say thank you to him just for being
there just being a real genuine person
just being loving and caring at somebody
I can count on no matter what we didn't
have much but coming up my grandmother
tried our best and wherever she slept he
picked it up for me he made sure I had
sneakers and clothes and a lot of stuff
like that and I appreciate that on on my
ended with on a funny story about um he
was the biggest LeBron James fan and I
remember I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the NBA but when the
Cavaliers they came back on the Golden
State Warriors and the finals and I
remember the very first phone call and I
told him man you too happy you sound
like you want to check your [ __ ] we
laughed about it there you know he said
man you know how I feel about LeBron I
did win the championship so every time
we would talk and I asked him but hey
how you doing man you're good and he and
he said I feel like I want a
championship and that kind of stuff it
was just his inside thing we had so I
know him being a strong person he was
and seeing everybody come together and
just rally around them and it stand out
of the love and support our family and
and we thankful and grateful and I know
more than anything with everybody
grieving and hurting here we want us to
feel like we won the championship so I
end on that note
thank you
[Applause]
yeah please give this family another
round of applause please show them thank
you all so much for bearing your hearts
if we learnt one thing the floor boys
like to eat and also they had a
conversation with Tyler Perrin it was
pretty profound because they said we are
the big extended black family that you
portray will packet and others on your
movie screens because we all need one
another and you can tell this family
always need it George
and so it's awfully difficult for them
the plea for justice is simply this dr.
Martin Luther King said he who passively
accepts evil is as much involved in it
as he who helps to perpetrate it he who
accepts evil without protesting against
it is really like cooperating with it
you know T on that video what we saw was
torture
Reverend Johnson what we saw in that
video was inhumane
more in the third what we saw in that
video was evil and so America we
proclaim as we've memorialized George
Floyd do not cooperate with evil protest
against evil John two young people in
the streets protesting against the evil
the inhumane the torture that a witness
on that video
we cannot cooperate with each evil
we cannot cooperate with injustice we
cannot cooperate with torture because
George Floyd deserve better than that we
all deserve better than that his family
deserve better than that his children
deserve better than that Steve all
George wanted from life is what any of
us want as Thomas Jefferson said in the
Declaration of Independence the an alien
above rights endowed by our Creator
Therese to life liberty in the pursuit
to be happy on this earth that's all
George was asking for like any and all
of us but he was denied those rights and
we will seek justice in his name we will
all United as a people who are God's
children seek justice in his name but
beyond the specific justice in his case
Chris the prosecution of the for
individuals who deprived George of his
life we seek a broader
more transformative justice revenue and
more jests system of policing Kevin a
more just treatment of people of color
Chris a more jest
criminal justice system in essence what
we are endeavoring to do Brandon is what
my personal hero Thurgood Marshall said
make the constitutional make the
Constitution real for all Americans
you see justice Marshall said the basis
of the Constitution is simply this that
a black baby born to a black mother the
most an educated black mother the most
inarticulate black mother the most
impoverished black mother has the same
exact race as a white baby born to a
white mother the most educated white
mother the most articulate white mother
tears the most affluent white mother
just by virtue of that baby draw on his
first breath as an American not Justice
Marshall said Reverend Jackson I know
that's not the case in America today but
I challenge anybody to say Tony that
that's not the goal we're fighting for
he said I challenge anybody to say
that's not what makes America the great
beacon of hope and justice for all the
world to Marvel so when we fight for the
Georges floors of the world but more
importantly when we fight for the
unknown
George floors of the world when we fight
for the Trayvon Martin's in the world
when we fight for the term scratch
little world when we spike for the
makeup brands in a world where we fight
without distillers in a world will we
fight but if Orlando cos fields in the
world when we say footage Amaya clocks
in a world when we've made for the Eric
Garner's in a world when we've made for
the stand your bleeds in a world when we
make one of my operas in a world where
we've paid for the Briana tailors in the
world when we've made for the Natasha
McKinney's of the world when we've made
for this Stephan Clark's in a world when
we made for the least of these what we
are really doing it's helping America
come live up to its Creed well what
we're really doing is helping America be
the great beacon of hope and justice for
all the world to Marvel but most
importantly brothers and sisters what we
are doing is helping America be America
for all Americans
[Applause]
what we want tea is not to justice
systems in America one for black America
and one for white America what we
endeavor to achieve is equal justice for
the United States of America and George
Floyd is the moment that gives us the
best opportunity I have seen in a long
time of reaching that high idea that
this country was founded on thank you so
much
this is the plea for justice on behalf
of the family the children we will get
justice we are committed to it I would
introduce you to a man who really needs
no introduction
who will eulogized George Floyd
he is a man who has fought for so many
families that too many hashtags to
remember and when he gets the call he
always answers the call even when the
cameras on around even after the cameras
are gone s Eric Garner's family asked
Stefan Clark's family any of these
families the chemists have long gone
Toni but Reverend L continues to answer
the bell when our people call he is a
leader that you see on TV commentating
about our experiences but more
importantly here's a leader who has
lived eye experiences and because he
have lived those experiences that's what
makes him so effective in commentating
on MSNBC about our experiences and he is
going to talk about the experience of
the
terrible loss of somebody who should be
with us today and that is George for
Laura please give a great round of
applause for the Reverend Al Sharpton
[Applause]
thank you I want us to not sit here and
act like we had a funeral on the
schedule
George Floyd should not be among the
deceased he did not die of common health
conditions he died of a common American
criminal justice malfunction he died
because of there has not been the
corrective behavior that has taught this
country that if you commit a crime it
does not matter whether you wear blue
jeans or a blue uniform you must pay for
the crime you commit
[Applause]
so it is not a normal funeral it is not
a normal circumstance but it's too
common and we need to deal with it
let me ask those of you that in the
traditions of eulogies need a scriptural
reference go to Ecclesiastes 3rd chapter
first verse says to everything there is
a time and a purpose and season under
the heavens I'm going to leave it there
I saw somebody standing in front of a
church the other day wood had been
boarded up as a result of violence held
the Bible in his hand I've been
preaching since I was a little boy I
never seen anyone hold a Bible like that
but I'll leave that alone but since he
held the Bible if he's watching us today
I would like him to open that Bible
and I'd like him to read Ecclesiastes 3
- every season there's a time and a
purpose and I think that it is our job
to let the world know when we see what
is going on in the streets of this
country and in Europe around the world
that you need to know what time it is
first of all we cannot use Bibles as a
prop and for those that have agendas
that are not about justice this family
will not let you use George as a prop if
you want to get your stuff off don't use
him let us stand for what is right
because when when I got the call from
attorney Crump and usually when he calls
me is not to find out how I'm doing it's
usually because something happened that
he wants National Action Network and I
to get involved and he explained to me
what was happening with this case and I
had already heard about it in the media
and immediately I said well let me know
what you want me to do he said whatever
you need to do one of the things Martin
that I've always had to deal with his
critics would say all our shelter wants
is publicity well that's exactly what I
want because nobody calls me to keep a
secret
people call me to blow up issues that
nobody else would deal with I'm gonna
blow up man and I don't apologize for
that cuz you get away too much with
hiding things
honey it's talked about y'all putting
clothes in the oven to have your clothes
dried well I think we're in the third
world but I grew up in Third Ward I grew
in Brownsville and we had roaches not
know Kevin Hart and some of the rich
Hollywood folk here don't know where
roaches are but we had roaches Ludacris
and one thing I found out about roaches
is that if you keep the light off
if you're in the dark
a roach will pull up to your dinner
table and have a five-course meal so I
learned one of the ways to deal with
roaches is if you cut the light off I
could run them roaches and track them
down and I've spent all my life chasing
roaches all over this country
[Applause]
soon as I talked to the family and got
the details and heard that among
George's last words was I can't breathe
putting me on his neck I immediately
thought about air Gardiner I did the
eulogy at his funeral and I called his
mother and I said I know we're not going
out because of the coronavirus but this
is so much like Eric if we could arrange
some private way to go to Minneapolis
would you go and she said read mal I'm
already packing let me know Tyler Perry
said I'll get the families the plane
whatever y'all need because this is
wrong Robert Smith said don't worry
about the funeral cause people across
economic and racial lands started
calling and getting in and we flew out
here her in our last Thursday and when I
stood at that spot reason it got to me
is George
Floyd story has been the story of black
folks because ever since 401 years ago
the reason we could never be who we
wanted and dreamed to be in is you kept
your knee on our neck
we were smarter than the underfunded
schools you put us in but you had your
knee on our neck we could run
corporations and not hustle in the
street but you had your knee on our neck
we had creative skills we could do
whatever anybody else could do but we
couldn't get your knee off my neck what
happened to Freud happens every day in
this country any
exit every area of American life is time
for us to stand up in George's name and
say get your knee off that's the problem
no matter who you are we thought maybe
we had a complex - yeah maybe it was
just us but even blacks that were broke
through you kept your knee on that neck
Michael Jordan won all these
championships and you kept digging for
mess cuz you've got to put a knee on our
neck weight housewives would run home to
see a black woman on TV named Oprah
Winfrey and you mess with her cuz you
just can't take your knee off our neck
man comes out of a single-parent home
educates himself and rises up and
becomes the president of the United
States and you asked him for his birth
certificate cuz you can't take your need
of our neck the reason why we're
marching all over the world is we were
like George
we couldn't breathe not because there
was something wrong with our lungs but
be you wouldn't take your knee of our
neck we don't want no favors just get up
off of us and we can be and do whatever
we can be
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
there then protests all over the world
some have looted and done other things
and none of us in this family condones
looting or violence but the thing I want
us to be real cognizant of is there's a
difference between those calling for
peace and those calling for quiet some
of y'all don't want peace you just want
quiet you just want us to shut up and
suffer in silence
the overwhelming majority of the people
March 1 breaking windows they were
trying to break barriers they weren't
trying to steal nothing they were trying
to get back to justice you stole from us
those that broke the law should pay for
whatever Lord a broke with so should the
4 policemen that caused his funeral
today we don't have a problem denouncing
violence mr. governor
we don't have a problem mr. mayor
denouncing Lewton but it seems like some
in the criminal justice system have a
problem looking at a tape and knowing
there's probable cause and it takes a
long time for you to go and do what you
see that you need to do
[Applause]
but I'm one that has been krump said -
and they're working I've been involved
in a lot but these fights we started
around criminal justice I did speeches
and eulogies that most of the funerals
that we've had in his face in the last
couple of decades and led to marches and
did what we had to do I look at Martin
2/3 we went to jail together fighting
these fights like his daddy went to jail
before but I'm more hopeful today than
ever
why well let me go back room Jackson
always taught me stay on your texts come
back to my texts ecclesiastic there is a
time and a season and when I looked at
this time and saw marches where in some
cases young White's outnumbered the
blacks much I know that it's a different
time and a different season when I
looked and saw people in Germany
marching for George flooring it's a
different time and a different season
when they went in front of the
parliament in London England and said
it's a different time and a different
season I come to tell you America this
is the time of building with
accountability in the criminal justice
system
[Applause]
speed years ago I went to March
now remember young white lady looked me
right in the face he said [ __ ] go home
but when I was here last Thursday and
Miss Carr and I was headed back to the
airport I stopped near the police
station and I was talking to a reporter
a young white girl she didn't look no
older than 11 years old she tagged my
suit jacket and I looked around and I've
braced myself and she looked at me and
said no justice no peace there's a
different time it's a different seat and
if my Bible carrying God in front of
that boarded-up church if I got him to
open up the Bible I want you to remember
something you know I was late last
October to an appointment because the
time changed and I was still my watch
was on the wrong time no once a year
time goes forward and if you don't
congresswoman oh my move your watch you
gonna find yourself hour late not
because your watch was wrong but you had
your watch on the wrong time well I come
to tell you that are sitting in
Washington talking about militarize in
the country thinking that you can sell
wolf tickets to people who's had enough
of abuse I come to tell you you can get
on the TV but you are in the wrong time
time is out for not holding you
accountable time is out for you making
excuses time is out for you trying to
stall time is out for empty words and
empty promises time is out for you
filibustering and trying to stall the
arm of Justice this is the time we
won't stop we go keep going until we
change the whole system of justice our
organizations have called us a day among
in a ACP now sherbet Lee Legal Defense
Fund black woman's round table lawyers
committee all got together said we gonna
have a day of mourning but then we gonna
come out this dear morning cuz that some
of our experts sherrilyn Ifill and
others that know the legal feel they've
outlined a legal process that we must
enforce everything from residency to
dealing with police background and not
being hidden talked to Governor Andrew
Cuomo today in New York he says we got
to change 58 where the backgrounds
stop or policeman we need to know if
they stop you they find out everything
you ever did why don't we know when
policemen have a pattern we gotta go
back to consent decrees under the Obama
administration they had put certain
cities with patterns and practice under
consent decrees from Jamal Bryant no we
use pastoring in Baltimore they put it
under consent decree one of the first
thing that happened in the next
administration was they stopped the
consent decrees we have specific
policies that need to happen
therefore I'm glad mod in the third is
here today because in August 28th the
57th anniversary of the march on
Washington we're going back to
Washington Martin that's where your
father stood in the shadows of the
Lincoln Memorial and said I have a dream
where we going back this August 28 to
restore and recommit that dream to stand
up because just like at one era we had
to fight slavery another area we had to
fight Jim Crow another era we dealt with
voting rights this is the era to deal
with policing and criminal justice we
need to go back to Washington and stand
up black white Latino era in the shadows
of Lincoln and tell them this is the
time to stop this
[Applause]
we Martin and I talked about this I've
had written Bryant to get the faith
leaders together talk brandywine God
about the labor leaders oh no we're
going to organize in the next couple
months in every region not only for
March but for new process and it's gonna
be led by the Froy family and it's gonna
be led by the garner family and it's
gonna be led by those families that have
suffered this and knows the pain and
knows what it is to be neglected and
it's going to be getting us ready to
vote not just for who's gonna be in the
White House but the State House and the
City Council's that allow these policing
measures to go on question we are going
to change the time let me say this to
the family who has shown such great
grace and let the real level and
balanced thinking and that's why I want
them to help lead this and I won't think
one of the greatest thinkers of our time
dr. Michael Eric Dyson ivax come on
speak we need to break down cuz ya'll
don't know what time it is y'all are
operating like is yesterday and the
reason y'all late catching up to what
these protest means
because you didn't turn your clock
forward talk about make America great
great for who and great win we gonna
make America great for everybody for the
first time never was gripping for blacks
never was great for Latino what never
great for others wasn't great for women
no women had to march to get the right
to vote but lastly is the religious side
I was reading and kept thinking about
how I was a little embarrassed because
when I heard that George at this point
of suffering this brutal attack call for
his momma I said to turn the Crump I
said well I appreciate talking to his
brothers and him on the phone but I
won't talk to his mother he said his
mother passed I said his mother passed
but he was calling for his mother and I
thought about it because I was raised by
a single mother and sometimes the only
thing between us and our conditions was
our mothers sometimes the only thing
that we had that would take danger away
was our mothers the only ones that would
make sure that food was on the table was
our mother I know why George was calling
for Mama but then as I had got that all
placed in my mind and I realized why I
was always calling and my mother died
eight years ago but I still try to talk
to her sometime just dialing cell phone
to hear your boy smell a dog phone that
I never cut off I still want to reach
out to mama but talking to Quincy last
night one of his five children quizes
said
you know I was thinking maybe he was
calling his mother cuz at the point that
he was dying
his mother was stretching her hands out
saying come on George
I welcome you when a wicked will cease
from troubling when a we're in will be
at rest there's a place where police
don't put knees on your George there's a
place that prosecutors don't drag their
feet maybe mama said come on George
there's a God that still sits hot but he
looks down low and he'll make a way out
of no way this God it's still on the
throne reason we can fight I don't care
who's in the White House there is
another house they said if we'll fight
he'll fight our battles if we stand up
he'll hold us up so as we leave here
today I say to this family I know that
years ago we told him Reverend Jackson
told us keep hope alive then I know that
President Obama wrote a book about hope
but I want you to know in my life
there's times that I lost hope things
can happen like this that a - your hope
but it's something that is sister to
hope call faith faith is the substance
of things hoped for the evidence of
things unseen faith is when you got a
pile of bills and no money but you say
he will provide all of my needs faith is
when you got no medicine in the cabinet
and you're sick in your body but you say
he's a doctor that never lost the
patient and he'll cry tears from my eyes
faith is when your friends walk out when
your loved ones turn their back
but the sad
believe he brought me this far to need
me now
we didn't come this far by luck we
didn't come this far by some faith we
come this far by faith leaning on the
Lord trusting in his holy word he never
he never he never failed me yet from the
outhouse to the White House we come a
long way God will God shall God will God
always hands he'll make a way for his
children go on home George get your rest
George you changed the world George
we will keep marching George we won't
keep fighting George we don't turn the
cop George we won't follow George time
out time out
[Music]
firewalker reacts gospel great Hezekiah
Walker sing a song for the family after
which Derrick Johnson of the n-double
a-c-p
[Music]
actually attract a crowd we won't stand
for 8 minutes and 46 seconds though that
was a time that George was on the ground
and we want you all over the world to
stand with us for 8 minutes and 46
seconds and make that commitment for
justice in the name of George I want to
thank the members of the Congressional
Black Caucus for being with us
won't you stand I want to thank the son
and heir and Koch Avena dr. Martin
Luther King the third for being with us
wanna thank the mayor and the governor
and their Brides for being with the
family senator Amy Klobuchar of the
state of Minister of Minnesota I want to
thank our my mentor and one who's fought
this fight for more than a half a
century the Reverend Jesse Lewis Jackson
is with us and his spokesman for Rainbow
PUSH Jonathan Luther Jackson
I want to thank I want to thank from the
entertainment world Kevin Hart he told
me don't mention these here so don't
clap
stand up Kevin we choke each other
brother beloved stand up brother brother
Ludacris
[Applause]
Tyrese Gibson whose extraordinary
activist in his own right Master P the
one and only the creative genius will
packet is with us today and brother if
we've marched together and done a lot of
things he does not just put his name on
somebody's petition he puts his body on
the line brother Ti is in the house this
brothers one of the greatest gospel
singers alive oh wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute I I didn't want to
announce and say I'm barrister let me
tell you something one of the most
popular outstanding artists that is also
committed I've read our interview she
think I'm old and don't read stuff but I
do and she's been committed and saying
the right things and she wanted to be
here today and I was so busy joking
would Kevin not even look at her let us
welcome our sister beloved sister
Tiffany Haddish is in the house
[Applause]
well I'm worn out all the rest with me
y'all I'll start introducing folk I got
em all let us hear selection from
whether Hezekiah Walker let's everybody
let's have some church for a little
while y'all ready after church
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
my condo right as we remain standing
wanna recognize cried Bella Court of the
American Indian Movement drop the bella
card we honored that you came thank you
and let me say they recognize someone
yell out the state chair been double ACP
and many of black lives matter
many of the grassroots organizations
that have been doing the protest on the
ground in many annapolis and around the
country movements are about everybody we
don't exclude anybody those young folks
some of them organic some organized on
their own some in ACP some urbanely
some Nash Action Network we need
everybody this is not a competition this
is a movement and we need to stop our
competing and start fighting the real
enemy thank you for doing what y'all are
doing it when I got here they will march
you and they kept marching they didn't
need nobody to come overnight some they
organized and we don't stay organized
and I really thank them for their work
we want to pause for eight minutes and
46 seconds
I want you we because of the pandemic
I'm not gonna actually to take hands but
I want you to stand next to someone with
the right distance amazing thing about
this movement people said they'd never
seen marches all over the country well
we've had that but we never had it in a
pandemic the reason I know this is a
different time his people came out by
the hundreds of thousands at risk of
their own health to stand up people that
had been sheltered in
broke out of shelter first flight I took
was to come here in many weeks and maybe
in God's own way Mardan in fact we were
sheltered means we could watch sports
couldn't watch nothing we had to keep
watching that tape maybe because we had
no distractions that finally we're ready
to deal with this
so as we stand I would like us to stand
together and I think the only one woman
appear I want Oh Tiffany as I was
disrespectful would you come stand with
us
OPA Tiffany Haddish so you won't be
talking about me in your next interview
I would like the mother of our Ghana
who's mother of the one who originally
died at police custody saying I can't
breathe to stand with me and Ben Crump
on stage his plane car let us stand
somebody said Reverend eight minutes is
a long time it was long enough for the
police to understand what they were
doing the meeting was long enough for
one of them three cops to stop what was
going on that means it was long enough
for whatever this office had in mind to
him to rethink as you go through these
long eight minutes think about what
George was going through laying there
for those eight minutes begging for his
life heard someone say narrating his own
death we can't let this go we can't keep
living like this
Sam Jackson is Sam still here we Steve
Jackson Steve Jackson is here Steve we
were recognized I was recognizing
everybody we got to stop this here and
we got to end this time
provided Lucy's let us stand still you
that believe in faith by your heads or
whichever way you worship
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just longtime if we've calculated with
the clock here that's how long he was
laying there there's no excuse at enough
time at enough time now what will we do
for the time we have as we I should have
family out please let us take them out
first they have to prepare to go to
North Carolina and then back Euston
where we will do the final services they
appreciate you all for come and let us
everybody else be seated but the family
Reverend Bryant will you come quickly
give us a benediction just a benediction
and we're going to take the family out
everyone else remain in your seats
[Music]
[Music]
your remain where you are for the
benediction good and gracious God
merciful master walk with us while we
run this race speak to us as we lift our
voice use our hand so that they do not
become fists change our hearts so that
our rage will shift to rehabilitation
convict the country so it can finally
beat the land of the free and the home
of the brave
we pray this prayer in the name of a
innocent black man by the name of Jesus
who is killed by a government and still
rose again and with that power we march
on until victory is won should a family
please everyone please be seated
except the family less less less please
everyone please remain in your seat as
we escort this family out thank you so
much please please we need everyone to
be main seated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on can you please remain seated for
a minute to exploit the family out
please let this family out
thank you so much for your cooperation
thank you so much for respecting this
family thank all those who respected the
family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we want to say thank you to everyone who
has come today we want to say how much
we appreciate taking your time and we
are dismissed at this time and make your
way safely
respectfully as you depart from the
sanctuary have a wonderful day much
involved in it as he who helps to
perpetrate it he who accepts evil
without protesting against it is really
like cooperating with it you know T on
that video what we saw was tortured
Reverend Jackson what we saw in that
video was inhumane Martin the third what
we saw in that video was evil and so
America we proclaim as we memorialize
George Floyd do not cooperate with evil
protest against evil
join the young people in the streets
protesting against the evil the inhumane
the torture that they witness on that
video
we cannot cooperate with each evil
we cannot cooperate with injustice
we cannot cooperate with torture because
George Florida's are better than that we
all deserve better than them his family
deserve better than that
his children deserve better than their
[Applause]
you
I'm just man it's crazy man all these
people came to see my brother and that's
amazing to me that he touched so many
people hearts you know cuz he been
touching our hearts you know you come to
third war where we're from people are
crying right now that's how much they
love them you know I'm just staying
strong as I can because I need to get it
out I need to get it out everybody won't
justice we want justice for George he's
gonna get it he's gonna get it
[Applause]
we didn't come this far by luck we
didn't come this far by some faith we
come this far by faith leaning on the
Lord trusting in his holy word he never
he never he never failed me yet from the
outhouse to the White House we come a
long way God will God shall God will God
always hand he'll make my way for his
children
go on home George get your rest George
you changed the world George
we will keep marching George we won't
keep fighting George we don't turn the
cup judge we won't fall in George
timeout
I saw somebody standing in front of a
church the other day wood had been
boarded up as a result of violence held
the Bible in his hand we didn't come
this far by luck we didn't come this far
by some faith we come this far by faith
leaning on the Lord trusting in his holy
story has been the story of black folks
story has been the story of black folks
because ever since 401 years ago the
reason we could never be who we wanted
and dreamed to be and as you kept your
knee on our neck
we were smarter than the underfunded
schools you put us in but you had your
knee on our neck we could run
corporations and not hustle in the
street but you had your knee on our neck
we had creative skills we could do
whatever anybody else could do but we
couldn't get your knee off my neck what
happened to Freud happens every day in
this country and education and health
services and in every area of American
life it's time for us to stand up in
George's name and say get your knee off
our necks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you